so you've been actually on the
promotional bandwagon where have you
been in the last like week I was in I
just came from San Francisco is up at
Skywalker Ranch should we screen it for
some folks there which is fun and San
Francisco right before that I was in
Paris it's a rough life
[Laughter]
Philly Denver Chicago Toronto Austin
we've been turning around and and
showing the movie it's been really
really fun before we go any further I
just want to give a huge thank you to
everyone for coming out tonight to see
the movie early thank you guys so much
for being here
a huge thank you to Lionsgate for
letting us screen the movie early a huge
thank you to our Clyde cinemas for being
an awesome partner and I just want to
make sure that if anyone is going to be
yeah you know every movie you could use
the the support so if you're actually
gonna push it on social tonight on
Twitter or Instagram or anything if you
could tag it with knives out and
Collider screenings and Arclight cinemas
that would be awesome now let's jump
into why we get to be here dad the last
year I'm just trying to get the good
good word out so I have a bunch of
questions about the movie but I have a
few what I'm gonna term fun questions oh
boy to throw out some some curve guess
what TV show would you love to guest
write and direct you know what I've been
watching this might be cheating cuz it's
a bygone TV show I've been watching a
ton of old Columbo recently and oh my
god that would be that would have been
but the people who like I mean obviously
Spielberg did early episode of that but
then Ben Gazzara director an episode of
it Jonathan Demi directed an episode of
it I'm on time careful machine
what what movie do you think you've seen
the most it's a toss-up between Treasure
of the Sierra Madre topsy-turvy by
Michael E oddly it's a comfort food
movie for me and what is maybe the third
one Miller's Crossing probably is there
anything that you collect no I'm not a
big collector you know I do collect this
is this will shock to you this is nerdy
the I collect infocomm games I know if
you guys know is text adventures
infocomm games like Zork and that kind
of stuff I was really into that when I
was a teenager I lost all of my old
games and I've read like just a few
years ago went on eBay and just kind of
started collecting the old like boxes
that they came in everything that's it
yeah I'm sorry no I think everyone has
actually done something like that gone
on eBay and bought something that they
had when they were a kid yeah yeah what
is the last TV
what does last thing you've injured
watched oh god the land besides Columbo
you mean chase oh my god god I can't
remember it's been so piecemeal in terms
of whether I just what I've watched I
just started watching Watchmen I think
it's fantastic I just watched the first
episode wash man how about that I'm
excited to binge watch that so for that
first step is so good man is closing
down then it the dawn essence is
occurring what is the team have you seen
have you ever watched a TV show all the
way through more than once yes
Deadwood which is a masterpiece yeah
yeah it's Deadwood is uh it's hard to
oversee and it was nice because I
watched your first years ago and then I
rewatched it recently with my wife who I
didn't expect to be into it and she was
so into it it made me as happy it's just
it's the writing in that show is just
godlike it's amazing
my last quote-unquote fun question do
you remember your first movie or TV show
rush yeah I'm sure I do let me think
back how far back - should we go here
you know I had a big crush this is a TV
show it's not my first cuz this would
have been like when I was I don't know
how old I was absolutely fabulous the TV
show the British one I had a huge crush
on Julia Sawalha who played like the
nerdy daughter plays Saffy and I just
thought she it was like that's that's
the kind of girl I want to end up with
someday Saffy is jumping into I get to
talk to you tonight and why everyone's
here I had the idea for this about 10
years ago I had just kind of like the
very basic like what if this happened
then this happened would be interesting
to do in a murder mystery where this was
kind of the structure of it I had that
about 10 years ago so I guess it's been
about 10 years since I've been kind of
chewing on this but I only sat down to
write the script last year it happened
it all happened actually really fast
when I sat down to write it when you
were writing it did you have the cast in
mind or was it no I've learned not to do
that because that's that's a path to
heartbreak because inevitably they're
not available even if they're your
friends and evitable is something will
come up and it won't happen so I just
write just I would just write the
characters and then we sit down and I
sit down with my casting director at
Mary ver new and we start going through
it and seeing who's available everyone
saw the movie tonight you put together
this murderers row of actors and what a
lot of people don't realize is
scheduling is next to impossible so how
the f did you do this well I'll tell you
how I [ __ ] did it is cast Daniel Craig
Craig was the first one to sign on so
he's the reason that and so
timeline-wise with this I'm a started
writing last January January of 2018 and
we had wrapped the movie by Christmas so
I spent about six months writing and
then what happened was Daniel wasn't
available and then he suddenly was
because bond pushed a few months so it's
like he had a couple of months of a
window and we jumped on it and that also
meant though from when he said yes
we had six weeks until we had to start
filming so that actually I mean it was I
I guess I can I can say you know it was
quite nice that we couldn't get precious
my poor producers standing over there
I'm sure it was not nice for him but one
of the ways I think it actually helped
us casting wise well you're asking about
you know if you if you go to famous
actors and you say do I do this thing
we're doing it's fall of next year
I think everyone's kind of doing the
math in their head like oh what if you
know a Marvel movie or something comes
up I want to kind of keep my options
open
with this it was literally are you
available right now can you come to
Boston and Daniel Craig's in it and it
just started kind of like and then
Michael Shannon was the next one to sign
up and then the question is even better
it's can you come to Boston right now
Daniel Craig and Michael Shannon are in
it and it just got better and better
with each actor and it's snowballs I
guess true or false that Chris Evans
worked for Dunkin Donuts well that makes
so much sense cuz he's from Boston he
was a local hire he was he could draw he
drove to work in the morning donkeys hey
we did have done that sunset or that I
would be shocked if he didn't work at
Dunkin Donuts oh they put it that way
yeah yeah I mean I everyone from Boston
I'm from Boston lives in our Brooklyn
it's like in the blood so talk a little
bit of though what surprised you about
the cast because each person each actor
works a little differently some might
like more take some might like less how
what is it like when you have a cast
like this trying to sort of corral at
all I was really nervous as I had never
worked with a cast this big before and
all these big names and everything kind
of as the cast list grew I could read
grew more and more terrified and then
the truth is I showed up on set and it's
again I keep apologize it's the boring
thing everyone says we did actually all
get along never good it was actually
there was no like movie star egos or
anything nobody was difficult it was
actually just it felt a bit like summer
camp the shoot we were at this big
mansion in the middle of New England's
in-between takes the cast they wouldn't
go back to their trailers and get on the
phone with their agents or whatever they
would all go down in the basement wreck
of this mansion and I'll just hang
around like telling each other war
stories and like hanging around a pool
table and so it was just I don't know
but in terms of yeah and I think maybe
because you know because this is that it
is an ensemble and because it's a murder
mystery where as an audience you can
know what you're sitting down for and I
think as cast members they kind of were
like okay we get what this is so it
wasn't like there was a ton of heavy
digging to get to the heart of it
everyone showed up and clicked in pretty
easy and yeah it all went pretty smooth
what did you learn did you guys you guys
mustard on a table read no we didn't do
a table read
no yeah I don't I don't find table reads
that useful we did one for brick and it
was so disastrous we almost didn't make
the movie like now that's not true we
bet it was what we was horrible as
disastrous Joe and I were just like
sitting in the car together after the
table read looking each other I was like
if you want to leave I understand
I don't know table reads I guess for
something that's like very food like TV
I get it for comedy stuff I think I get
it for something like this especially
with a cinematic language of all the
cutting with the flashbacks is so
intricate to it I don't I don't know
yeah maybe I just haven't found what's
useful about them yet well I'm curious
so you get the cast together and
obviously you have a script are really
happy with does the script get altered
by the casting and the voices that
you're now hearing on these characters
it doesn't get altered in that way it's
not like we have this actor they could
you know we have to write it to their
skills or whatever mostly because all
these actors are so skilled I feel like
they can do whatever you throw at them
what does happen is I mean obviously
it's the nature of the script is kind of
like a jigsaw puzzle so it's not like
you can get on set and just start you
know [ __ ] around or something you
have to kind of stick to the stick to
the plan but you know because there was
fit this way like that when their scenes
where there was a lot of exposition to
be given by characters or we had to
explain something or the characters had
to do something if the actor couldn't
track exactly what was happening in that
moment and I knew the audience probably
wouldn't be able to either and so if an
actor came up to me and said I don't
quite understand why
doing this I wouldn't try and just talk
them into it I would always say okay
let's see if we can simplify it then and
so there was quite a bit of adjusting
Chris Evans was terrific at that I think
because he's done all the Marvel movies
that have so much check so much
exposition in them I think he was used
to kind of you know he had a very good
kind of you know [ __ ] detector in
terms of does this actually track it
makes sense
on a on a dramatic level on the scene
how much when you're writing the script
you said you wrote it for six months how
much did it change along the way like
I'm curious so on day one you're sitting
down to write this thing how much do you
know the entire arc how much are you can
you sort of talk about because it's it's
all about figuring out where to give
information and there's so many little
things
Deborah then and with this one in
particular I write really structuralist
I have to start I really I spend I spend
this the first big chunk of time just
working in little notebooks and all I do
is I draw like arcs and split them out
into like sequences I need to basically
be able to see the whole plot in my head
before I can sit down and actually start
writing or I'll get lost in the weeds so
I plan and plan and plan and plan and
this was like that only more so this was
even more crucial for me to have the
whole thing mapped out but then you
actually get into it and as you guys are
writers you know you get into it and no
matter how much you plan you know it's
it's like you you plan out your map
through the forest looking at like the
map and in your cozy living room and
then you get in there and you're
actually hacking through the forest and
you figure out stuff doesn't work and
figure out new paths and so yeah it's
kind of a mixture I guess we don't want
to get into spoilers but I am curious
was the ending in this film always the
ending or did you have multiple ideas
now I rarely have multiple ideas and
lucky if I have one yeah no this is
because well no actually the real answer
is like because I approach it in that
structural way I started with a very
zoomed back concept the basic first idea
wasn't oh what if this person is the
killer and kills the person this way and
they figure out this way it wasn't even
that it
the idea of taking whodunits
and putting the engine of a Hitchcock
thriller in the middle so you know
Hitchcock like famously hated whodunits
because he thought there were one big a
lot of build-up for one big surprise at
the end which to him was like the
cheapest coin possible and to him
suspense is is where it's all that in
terms of narrative so the idea I love
whodunits but I also kind of see where
he's coming from so I thought well what
if we kind of can take the engine of
like an empathy based suspense movie put
that in the middle of a whodunit but
then still have the bookends of a great
whodunit and still get all the stuff I
love about their whodunit in there so
the idea of how that wouldn't work and
I'll talk her I won't go into it because
of spoilers but that but that was as it
was that broad actually wasn't even
thinking about characters or place or
time or what happens even it was just
this kind of wonky genre exercise to
begin with I'm fascinated by the editing
process because it's the final rewrite
talk a little bit about what did you
learn in the editing room when you
finally started watching all the footage
this is why I worked with my editors Bob
do say and we've done their last two
movies together and he's really he's
incredible and I started out editing my
own stuff I said the brick I cut just
like on my computer in my bedroom like
I've always used to having my hands on
it and working with Bob has really
taught me kind of the value of a
collaborative relationship with an
editor and with this one it's
interesting because it's so intricate
and yet it kind of popped together
pretty quick and we ended up doing the
least amount of kind of big picture
shuffling of any of any of the movies
we've done together and it wasn't yeah
it kind of I mean we did a lot of work
to it it took a lot of refining and a
lot of the devil was in the details of
what we reveal when and and what we
linger on and whose perspective were in
but the thing as a whole actually like
it came together as a film really really
quick and kind of stayed that way did
you do a lot of friends and family
screenings any test screenings what did
you learn from those
we did a bunch of friends and family
screenings and that's just like you know
eight to ten people in a little room and
they're all your friends and if they're
you know if they negative you guys know
how it is with friends and I mean if you
just show stuff that you make to friends
of yours if they you know if they don't
like it you feel like the world is over
and if they do like it you think they're
lying to you
so but within this case it did it was
very very useful because be just because
of the what did you understand when who
did you suspect when and even just
getting information that oh this tipped
off for people that this was coming too
early or too strongly in that way it
helped a lot and then we tested it three
times he tested it once in Orange County
like a proper like screening a theater
like this a crowd like this but like
randomly recruited with cards and all
that stuff in testa in Orange County and
then twice out in Texas and the benefit
of that for me was really at that point
we had the whole thing pretty dialed in
it was it was really just encouraging
just to hear an audience react to it for
the first time and to die no it was it
was yeah it was the only time I would
attach the word fun to a test screening
but it was actually fun hearing it like
a big crowd react to react to the humor
in the movie for the first time when you
do test screenings I've heard from some
filmmakers that they'll go in the
bathroom and fitness as you'll hear
actual honest feedback that's terrifying
oh my god that's a really good idea
though I'm gonna I might I might use the
stall to vomit a couple of times but
that's like that's a very good idea I'm
gonna steal that idea yeah
first cut how long was it compared to
the finished film we well the we were I
was terrified because the first the the
shooting draft ROM do you remember how
long the shooting draft was one hundred
and twenty five hundred and thirty pages
about my even hundred and thirty I was
bracing myself for like Ahad we're gonna
have a two hour and 45 minute first cut
and our first assembly like the editors
assembly it was like two hours and
twenty minutes it was actually I think
because it cut on the screen much faster
than having to describe everything on
the page this wasn't a movie where we
were like oh my god how are we gonna cut
this down there are a couple of really
great scenes that we did that ended up
on the cutting room floor for pacing but
the movie was never outrageously long
which was a it was a real relief how
many how many did you how many scenes do
you have that were cut out of the film
there's really there's there's two
really good ones there's a great one
with Toni Collette and Daniel Ted
unfortunately we had to lose but we'll
get and they're in the home video
release not in the movie but we'll have
it as an extra and then there's another
really good one with Riki Lindhome who's
a fantastic comedian and actress who
she's half of a comedy duo called
Garfunkel & Oates and she plays Michael
Shannon's wife like they're really
nervous you know he's blond and there's
a great scene where we learn why Michael
Shannon is wearing a cast on his leg
that I really love but it's just one of
those things where it had nothing to do
with the scene just pacing wise we end
up slicing it up when you make when you
remove scenes like that do you actually
call the cast and say oh good you want
me to hang out in the bathroom and hear
about what people hate it you want me to
call the cast and tell the guy you're
just this is just a torture agents man
yeah and you know if I'll tell you if
someone's going to get cut out of the
movie then you cut you died you make a
call and you do like a courtesy call but
if somebody's in the movie and it still
is a great performance in the movie and
there's like one scene that got cut out
then yeah I mean depend of gauge it
depending but I mean all actors I mean
it's it's every you know that it's so so
so common actors are so used to it it's
not like a big heart you know maybe
there's a big heart breaker I don't know
yeah but yeah it goes with the job what
was the last thing you cut out before
picture locking meaning like that last
little bit yeah there was no like very
last yeah right before it went out the
door or something there was nothing
dramatic like that I think there was if
anything we were like sliding stuff back
in at the very last minute the baby
driver reference
I don't know if that was a good or good
I did good there bad idea but Weezy I
was like yeah alright okay good thank
you
very last minute I was like been the
last thing so you're welcome that group
are there any other Easter eggs or
things you would like people to look out
for well I mean seeing the movie the
second time there's a lot of fun stuff
in terms of stuff we hid in the
background with you know what actually
is happening kind of when you're not
aware they're even supposed to be
looking for it but that would be telling
there's oh you know this is fun the I
don't know if you guys are that so one
of the big references I gave David crank
our production designer for the inside
of the house is one of my favorite films
in 1970s version of sleuth with Michael
Caine and Laurence Olivier yes give
every sleuth and that along with death
trap were kind of big references for the
house but sleuth more so and we actually
those who know the movie sleuth there's
like a findt there's like a kind of a
statue of a drunken sailor jolly Jack
the sailor and we didn't get these
statue but we got a drunken sailor
statue and the lion kind of foyer of the
house in reference to sleuth it's
obviously we all know the title was it
almost called something else no it was
always called time so I find that and I
don't know if you guys find with your
stuff is like it's you I find anything
you do you either have the title really
early or it's a torturous like you can
never find it and you're finally just
like our [ __ ] we'll call it that okay
but this it was once I heard the
Radiohead song I just kind of filed it
away as that's a really cool turn of
phrase be a good murder mystery title
are you the type of person that has a
lot of unproduced scripts God now I wish
I really wish no I'm no I don't I I
finished something and then I kind of
sit down and figure out what I want to
do next and then and then and then work
on that which I guess is maybe I don't
know maybe that's good because it means
whatever I'm doing is the thing I'm it's
fresh in terms of its genuinely the
thing that
you know most excited about saying down
doing next I guess I don't know but God
that that would be nice drawer full of
scripts the cast is so incredible in the
movie
I'm curious maybe what surprised you
specifically about like a Chris Evans or
a Christopher or a Michael or if you
could name some of the people that you
worked with and maybe you know what I
mean I think so yeah I mean you know if
every one of them is so so different but
none that I mean there were no like big
surprises with ever anyone I mean Jamie
Lee Curtis is just the coolest person in
the world but that will surprise no one
she's like she is jamie is like the
she's got like a very like alpha nerd
energy in the coolest way possible she
was like the first one this set everyday
and and she would just hang out kind of
unset and like she's in scenes in the
movie she wasn't supposed to be in
because she was just there and I was
just like Oh Jamie Lee Curtis is here I
guess she must be in the scene she must
know what she's doing and I would stick
her in so and yeah what else I mean you
know who is who is really funny as
Michael Shannon Michael Shannon is
hilarious he's and he's like stealth
funny he's funnier because you don't
expect him to be as funny as he is
because he's so intense he's not really
as early a fun guy but he's like yeah
he's but he is he's really intense and
he's hilarious that he had a couple
there's a line in there races like I'm
not eating one iota of [ __ ] and like
stuff like that he would just he would
chuck out and you would just be like did
that just come out of Michael Shannon's
mouth that's amazing yeah yeah yeah and
yeah who else everybody else was like
cake Allen who plays a great Nana who is
actually 10 years younger than
Christopher Plummer
[Applause]
there's a lot of a lot of age makeup and
it gives it takes a lot to give like a
performance that's that nonverbal and
that good I think she did a really good
job I'm always curious how many how many
takes do you typically like to do when
you're on set just kind of as many as it
takes with this one it was not many
takes because the the cast was so dialed
in everyone clicked in very quickly to
what the thing was and I don't know I
felt there was a benefit to kind of
moving briskly and not like getting
bogged down it wasn't like we were you
know digging heavy-duty into any kind of
method stuff with it this was there the
cast kind of knew exactly what they were
going for and generally it was two three
takes and then moving on but it but I've
also I've done many more than that if
scenes call for it you know and in this
one it just happened to kind of breeze
by really quick this is the moment we're
gonna I'm going to attempt to get you to
throw someone under the bus who ruined
the most takes and why there was let me
think
yeah and that when Ana de Armas who I
haven't I haven't gushed about yet Ana
is I'm before I say why she ruin takes
I'm gonna say how amazing incredible she
is she's you ask me like who surprised
me the most I think because you know all
the other actors in this cast I like you
know I did you know their body at work
they're all movie stars and I had seen
her in Blade Runner I had watched some
other stuff of hers but really I just
cast her from just meeting her and just
you know having her read for the part
and she really has to you know for her
to step into the middle of this cast
like this big-name cast and kind of
giving all these big performances for
her to step into the center of that and
kind of effectively carried the movie
that like that that with that amount of
confidence she has I think I just think
she's extraordinary but when she gets
giggly when she gets the giggles and it
hurt mostly her and Chris they would
like get giggles and it was just be over
you'd have to just kind of step away for
like 10 minutes you know I mean getting
giggles
like something they just started to take
and they just start laughing
it's a thing that happens it's like an
infectious giggle thing and and the King
sometimes gathered no no I'm sorry
anybody yeah you guys know okay yeah
yeah okay you've worked with your
cinematographer Steve on I think all
your films talk a little bit about the
collaboration you guys have and what is
it like you know how much are you guys
setting up the shot you're gonna get
before you get on set how much can you
sort of talk about that collaboration
yeah I mean Steve and I we've we've met
when you know he was still a senior in
high school and I was a freshman in
college we met honest Jenna and film
said we've been making movies ever since
I hope to keep making them with them the
rest of my life
and yeah we it's if you hold on to those
you know relationships when they get
them
Steve's amazing he so I I bored out my
movies just even roughly I will I will
just do a first pass where I just kind
of like sketch out visually I'm just
because it helps me to show up with the
plan but then when we get on set
especially the more movies I make I tend
to just kind of let it I have that as
kind of in the back of my head but then
you have to feel out the rehearsal you
have to feel out the space and then I
you start getting into it and very often
it becomes a collaboration with Steve in
terms of figuring out how to cover a
given scene and the lighting I don't
have a head for lighting so I can
describe to Steve how I want it to feel
I can describe where I want light
sources but meaning like the lights
really coming in the window and the rest
of its darker I can give him references
but Steve is the one who really
translates that into how it's going to
work in the space I mean I think our
biggest kind of existential crisis on
this movie was this is the first film
we've shot entirely digital and i'm a
big big film guy and that was a real
crisis of faith for me that was like a
big discussion and steve is a real tech
head who you know he is a color science
guy and Steve's argument which look he's
right it's art it's hard to argue with
is
basically you can if you as an artist
take control over the post process and
you can make that image look however you
want it to make however you want to look
and seating control over the eventual
look by saying that what you shoot on is
what delivers the look is untrue and
turns you from an artist into a consumer
basically saying the brand I choose is
what makes it look the way it looks
the truth is with imaging technology
because everything goes through a
digital post chain at this point even
with film you're scanning it and doing
digital color correction you know you
have to if you own that process you can
make it look the way you want I wanted
to look like film there were a lot of
benefits of shooting digital and there's
exactly one thirty five millimeter shot
in the movie there's one shot of Daniel
in that last sequence that's shot on
thirty five film from my birthday
because Steve knew I was heartbroken he
I walked onto set and there he had
gotten Panavision to ship out like an
old 70s blimped camera like the type
they shot like jaws and stand and
Godfather on and and we shot one shot on
it and it really pisses me off that I
see the shot coming I see you had the
shot on either side of it and damned if
I can you know if I can tell the
difference it looks like the movie are
you done shooting on film then I don't
know man I can't say those words that's
too heartbreaking but it's just it's
just the entirely you know it's almost
like a religious thing it's almost just
like I understand it's an entirely
emotional thing because the truth is I
can't argue with the results I think the
movie looks beautiful and I think I've
had diehard film people watch it and
just say oh I'm so happy you shot on
film like I think it does when Steve
does his thing I think it's a it looks
great and the flip side of that is you
know there were movies shot on film
every year that looked like they were
shot on digital it's all about how you
handle it in post basically what cameras
is gonna get nerdy I'm so sorry what
camera so now it's going to get to use
and what lenses because a lot of times
people talk about how they'll shoot on
digital but then they'll use these Vince
winces or certain lenses yeah I mean we
you know we shot with the with the Alexa
not with like the 65 or anything crazy
just the regular Alexa and you know we
mostly use prime lenses I think which
ones we use the Primo's for this we use
very clean lenses they were not like
funky old like Krasnogorsk amber like
lenses or something from like that we
got on eBay or something we use just
like in a really good glass from from
Panavision and in mostly primes actually
and this is actually I mean more
interesting than the camera and the net
stuff this is the first movie since
brick that I've shot 185 as opposed to
widescreen ratio and that was really
interesting adjusting back to that
framing I found it really fun actually
going back to kind of that slightly
taller framing for for groups of people
it was interesting I'm about to open it
up to the audience I just want to be
clear before I open it up that we're
trying to stay spoiler free because
people are maybe filming and we're
trying to you know keep the spoilers in
the room thank you but I am curious
every time you speak to a filmmaker they
talk about in the editing room that
they'll repeatedly go back to like one
scene like one scene is the thorn in
their in their side what was as long as
we were things to spoiler-free was there
a scene that you repeatedly went back to
there wasn't one that was like god [ __ ]
it well you know there was one scene
that was like why can't we get this
working I don't know if I should tell
you guys though because now every time
you see the scene you'll be like oh yeah
that isn't great it's a it's done though
it's a really quick scene it's a scene
where rant where ransom and Martha are
kind of figuring out what to do with the
ransom note before they go to the before
they go to the burning building it's
kind of it feels like a nothing scene
but originally it wasn't originally it
was much longer I guess and it wasn't
working and we kind of figured that
those scenes usually the approaches you
can't strip them down so you find
exactly what they need to be usually if
a scene isn't working it's because it's
overridden and so you and the cutting
room is kind of figuring out you know
getting it down to kind of this the most
aerodynamic version of it let's I will
tell you that this light makes it
actually okay now wait I can finally say
I'm blind yes
does the audience have microphones are
we just gonna sort of scream it we can
scream it let's do it so I see a hand
right there I see some strong lungs and
the audience tonight thank you thank you
I love you and also I don't think anyone
who doesn't like the last year there's a
[ __ ] if anyone's filming this I don't
think that everyone has different
opinions about movies and so it I mean
what-what felt really good coming into
this was honestly like this the speed of
how fast we did it last Jedi I had the
best experience of my life I'm sure I'll
be on my deathbed and be thinking
that'll be kind of you know I don't know
I won't be able to die angry about
anything because I will have gotten when
I've worked and I've gotten to work in
the Star Wars world but it was four
years to make one movie and so it felt
really good to come and just like hit
this really quick and just do something
that we didn't get too precious about
and I don't know in terms of like you
know the the Jake Jacob character the
Nazi child masturbating in the bathroom
that's I mean that's not like a you know
it's I don't know it's I don't know if
you guys will believe me it's not an
actual specific thing against anything
Star Wars to me that's just the whole
thing the whole thing with this movie
was okay let's take a whodunit and plug
it in to 2019 let's make it modern day
and that means to me not just giving you
know Colonel Mustard a cellphone that
means the characters in it are gonna be
character types who you can only exist
in 2019 for better or
very worse and if you're on the internet
in any capacity you it's this is not a
phenomenon that's unique to Star Wars
there are just there are trolls who do
this kind of gamified version of
trolling which you know is ultimately at
the end the day kind of silly and boring
and I thought it would be fun to have a
laugh at it oh yeah I mean was I scared
showing up with all these guys yeah I
was [ __ ] my pants
I was really terrified but but they're
all fantastic actors and at the end of
the day that makes your job easy I guess
you know because what you're doing fine
tuning and you're not like oh my god can
we get it you're showing up and kind of
actually doing the work of fine tuning
and I also I mean you know big as much
as I get through Christie books we're a
big inspiration for this I grew up
watching like my favorite Agatha
Christie's are the ones where Peter
Ustinov plays Poirot
so it's death on the Nile evil Under the
Sun and those movies I guess Murder on
the Orient Express kind of started out
they're big they're very pointedly all
star casts that's one of the pleasures
we're putting on a big show this is a
spectacle and when we sat down and make
this movie I really consciously wanted
to do this I think I said to Rahm I said
you know we want an all-star cast with
this it's one of the things every person
who shows up you should say oh it's that
person you know you had that reaction so
yeah and I think I should get a piece
man piece of that action call it call
Barbara broccoli get on the phone no no
I don't I mean I don't know I did they
they worked what really well together in
Daniel you know they I'm sure that
something I do it but also I know she
had she had she told me she had met
before knives out she had met Carrie
before and she had met barber before and
so I think they had a relationship but
yeah I'm sure Daniel liked having a good
time working with her on this didn't
didn't hurt I'm so excited to see her
and it's gonna be fun and I'm excited
this year she just played Marilyn Monroe
is she has finished shooting in Andrew
Dominic's new movie which is gonna be
insane it's gonna be amazing she was
like showing me like camera tests she
was doing while we were unsaid so I'd be
like directing her all day as Marta and
then she'd show me her done up as
Marilyn Monroe and I'd be like who are
you also anything that Andrew does
should be a you know when those films
come out it's a national top of the list
completely man that guy's a beast yeah
yeah yeah no a hundred percent let's go
to the left Wow I see you right there
sure no no it actually would my family
I'm a really big family I'm really close
to them and they're nothing like the
family in this movie they're really
lovely amazing people mom
I'm looking right in the camera but but
I did grow up in a really big family and
you know the anyone who did you know the
family politics the family dynamic I
national pastime and our family is
having a good argument so and all the
tensions in the family and the politics
of just being in the big family so
there's nothing specific and this is
from my family but generally I think you
know just growing up in that kind of
loving environment that's also the game
of Thrones a little bit in the most
loving way
definitely informed it yeah he started
training as the instant we hired him and
he worked really intensely with a
dialect coach and I gave him the
reference of the historian Shelby Foote
to listen to this deep Mississippi
accent but Daniel is like a very trained
actor he's done a lot of theater I knew
that he could click into that accent
money when you needed to
yeah yeah good yeah I did I mean I did
one thing that I wanted to put a lot of
humor into it I wanted to be really fun
and but then also I was really I had to
be really clear when we started making
it that it was you know because I think
people's reference for these things
tends to be clue or murder by death
which I love those movies but I had to
be really clear hopefully there's a lot
of humor in that this is not a parody
this is it was a very fine line in terms
of we're doing a murder mystery here
we're not doing a parody of murder
mysteries thanks man appreciate ya Mike
yeah because of Nathan I we talked about
sharp strings I mean yeah so I hadn't
listened to a lot of Greek and a lot of
classical references this is Nathan's
first orchestral score I think he I'm so
proud of it man yeah
[Applause]
thank you yeah yeah yes you have to go
quick yeah thank you first of all the
big that for me the big lesson in this
movie was blocking large groups of
actors and because there were scenes in
this they had like eight or ten people
in them and the more and more that like
I think that when I was like I've been
so fat like I think you start out
thinking of camera angles in terms of
directing and thinking of cool camera
angles and camera moves and everything
more and more recently I start thinking
I think about blocking and staging what
we would call staging there's been some
really great videos recently about how
like Spielberg is a master of staging
his actors where they're standing in
relation to each other when they move
and then where the camera is in relation
to them and that me watch Michael Curtiz
movies he's a master of staging and so
yes staging large groups of people was
kind of the the thing that I felt like I
got the most practice with him this one
thanks
[Applause]
oh yeah the donut reference I'm not
remember when in the back of your
through a story behind the the drawn-out
drawn-out donut reference yeah I had
wanted just that I feel like in
mysteries it's kind of a fun trope that
the detective always has some kind of
nonsense elaborate kind of metaphor for
how his process works with the case or
something that doesn't really make sense
and so I wanted to get Benoit one of
those and I wrote it I almost cut it in
the script that's almost like as it's
doing that thing I don't know it's kind
of silly and Daniel was like let me try
something with and then he went at that
donut speech with like the fervor of
like a Pentecostal preacher or something
like just fire in his eyes I are
watching it being like I'm really glad I
didn't cut the doing this yeah Lionsgate
has been terrific in terms of involving
me and ROM in in all the trailers and we
don't like cut them or something like
they they cut them and then they take
feedback from us especially regarding
spoilers and there's it's tough it's a
really really fine line it's really hard
because you know you do have to kind of
sell the movie and but you have to be
really I'm very conscious I've been
probably a little oversensitive in terms
of what we give away now that you guys
have seen it I'll be curious if you
watch the trailer to see kind of like I
don't know whether you think it tips
anything I think out of context from
knowing the movie it we did we do okay
with it but it's always a fine line
yeah going from first to finally you
mean like during that process of
rewriting yeah yeah yeah I got I got a
couple of like trusted friends that I'd
show it to every time my producer is
someone I show it to and then just write
her friends really you know people that
you can like get that will really be
honest with you because you want
brutality in that fig you don't want
brutality but you need brutality in that
phase you know and then it's just
working it over and over and over again
and just trying to you know just
simplify simplify and just but you know
it sounds like you're ready you know
it's it's like it the tough balance is
always you get notes from people and you
realize trying to parse out with a very
small sample size what what notes you
want to what notes you need to you need
to get in there and do changes for and
what notes are you know either personal
preferences or quirks or how the person
was feeling that that's the part that
like I feel like you never quite figure
out you always kind of just gotta do
your best you know
yeah yeah I mean I think the in terms of
prepping it was I think we focused the
most on we didn't we got a little bit of
rehearsal time with the actors but not
much we got to we got to rehearse Anna
and Christopher Plummer in a really that
really crucial scene with them and we
got to do a little bit of her sing with
Daniel and Anna but mostly it was it was
largely the design it was the house it
was the deck the set deck in the house
it was the build a couple builds we had
to do and it was scouting locations and
finding locations because it was so fast
we kind of just had to do that the
essentials of it and then and then a lot
of work was Steve on like pre lighting
and stuff I say 17 or 18 times it is a
movie that's designed to be watched
multiple times I'll be excited to hear
from you how it stacks up yeah right
right there yeah yeah so that chair so
the chair is not attached to the big
nice thing the knife thing is kind of
like a big industrial barbecue great
with all these knives on it and I've had
it ran in the script as like a religious
icon made of knives and then we got on
set and I lined up my first shot I said
oh that looks great I put the chair in
front of it and put the person in the
chair and I said it's Game of Thrones
it's okay so I'd like Game of Thrones
she picked it she picked that song I was
like flipping through with my like you
know with my like [ __ ] that what I
thought she a dancer and she's sidles up
and she goes just put this on and I was
like okay so she picked it and then we
had to pay them clear it no but if
anyone reads about someone who has that
condition let me know because it wasn't
me that maybe wanted to meet them
ya know it just gave me a storytelling
thing and just making life as hard as
possible for that character take away
the one thing well the one tool they
have to get out of their situation and
do it kind of in the biggest splashes
way possible I guess
oh bring your families opening weekend
good now seriously if this movie I mean
I'd we'll see how this one does you know
but um Daniel and I had so much fun
doing if I could get together with them
and do a new Benoit Blanc every few
years I would that would love it we
almost got really cheeky and put like at
the end of the scroll Benoit Blanc will
return there we decided not to tempt the
fates
and yeah so Frank and I we became like
you know it became good friends working
on last Jedi and he's just a sweetest
man in the world and I you know I grew
up like watch seeing him pop up in
little roles and like the Blues Brothers
and I was like you think he'd come down
and then do it and he was I think he he
at least claimed he hated he hates being
on camera like just being on camera
and I couldn't tell if he was just
claiming that he actually loves it but I
don't think so I think he actually hates
it so I meant it meant so much to me he
was so incredibly kind to come down and
do it I think it just makes me so happy
to see him in their favorite scene to
shoot that's a tough one they're so
different I really love the ones with
the whole families together just because
the energy unsaid when you have all
those actors yelling at each other even
though it was kind of laborious with all
the coverage the energy in the room it's
just yeah yeah it's pretty cool yeah I
told them give him the apology saying
when there was a window XP computer give
him the shittiest laptop you can find
it's good I give them they give you the
laptop that my grandfather would have
basically right now so yeah
[Music]
yeah so the the idea that she was an
immigrant and the idea of that tying in
thematically to like the shape of the
whole thing that I had actually had for
a while that actually predated like the
election even that had been something
that had been an integral part of it but
then of course with the last few years
you know that really juiced it all and
made it just feel even more you know I
don't know even motivated me even more
to just be more and more explicit and of
course the stuff it's very explicit
about it we can do that because because
we because it all happened so fast you
know and even then while I was writing I
that was you know God that would it
would have been lovely if some of those
specific stuff had been dated and we had
to cut it out but unfortunately you know
that was Don Johnson yeah yeah the way
he just it he did it in one take and
right after we called cut everyone is
just like looking like did you just do
that that's amazing and we actually we
had two cameras rolling one interesting
little editing thing at one point we
because we have like a more frontal shot
of it where you see her take it and we
cut to that and then we realized at some
point it was it was much funny if we
said we're on kinda weird side angle
yeah it's almost incidental to the shot
and humor wise it was one of those
strange things in the Edit room we found
it worked much better if we didn't draw
attention to it
yeah yeah well thank you I'm glad that
you liked it I wanted to hold off the
point where he enters the conversation
so I wanted to just to kind of like hold
him back as this mysterious figure and I
thought okay well maybe there's a logic
to it like he's worked out this code
with detective Elliot where like when he
hits the piano key he's supposed to ask
a certain question and they have this
thing going on mostly though I just
wanted it to be kind of weird I wanted
us be leaning forward and saying wait
who is that guy so that when he finally
enters you're you've been kind of
leaning forward like okay we finally get
to meet this guy oh god it's been great
hear from movies god I mean you know
parasite is hard to beat I loved uncut
gems the lighthouse I loved there you
know there's a little movie that came
and went really quickly but the last
black man in San Francisco and now if
anyone got to see that I thought it was
gorgeous
the Irishman I can't get married Stuart
yeah I'm gavel sighs so no I'm gonna
have a hard time making it even my top
ten at the end of this year yeah I've uh
I've actually I want to interject real
quick and say I've been doing this for a
long time and this year has been on
we're in a good year guys yeah so could
uh get out there and see some movies
yeah oh my god feeling this crowd seeing
most of them yeah yeah
also this movie called knives out yeah
yeah just Sojo more than Levitt he's he
is detective hardrock you guys catch
where he he's the voice on the iPad and
the cop thing at the beginning he's like
we have the nanny cam footage that's Joe
doing his best doing his best David
Caruso and but I it's been a couple
movies now where I've had because I need
Joe and every movie I do and and it's
been a couple of movies now where I've
had to get man as a voice and I'm I'm
sick of it I want them in front of the
camera so hopefully hopefully next time
it'll work out yeah on that note I'm
just gonna say and I mean this sincerely
a huge thank you to Ryan Johnson I just
want to remind everybody that you know
every movie no matter how good it is can
always use the love on social because
social is really important so if you
enjoyed the movie please talk about it
hash tag knives out or is it knives out
movie I think it's just now I'm so and
if you're hanging on Thanksgiving and
you're sick of your terrible family drag
them to see this terrible family because
at least they're funny yeah and and
again if any of you guys are tweeting
about this tonight if you hashtag
Collider screening or Collider
screenings plural sorry Dorian Collider
screenings and I will retweet and embed
and all that stuff but huge thank you to
Lionsgate and Arclight and everybody for
being here so thank you guys so much
[Applause]